A memorable last scene can
make a good movie great.
But which Marvel movie really broke the mold?
What exactly was Nic Cage doing in The Wicker
Man? How did one British comedy inspire a
thousand funerals? Keep watching to find out.
Warning: Spoilers ahead for
all the movies discussed.
Fight Club, David Fincher's 1999 adaptation
of the 1996 Chuck Palahniuk novel,
is one of those movies where the big
twist ending forces you to reassess
everything you've just seen. The reveal that Tyler
Durden is the Narrator's alternate personality
might raise a little confusion about specific plot
mechanics, but it immediately brings the story's
themes into focus. Tyler is the unhealthy
projection of the Narrator's own rage,
self-loathing, and toxic masculinity, an
internal antagonist who needs to be defeated.
The climactic twist comes straight from the book,
but the movie offers its own spin on the ultimate
resolution. Though the Narrator kills Tyler,
Project Mayhem actually succeeds, and Tyler's
carefully planted bombs are detonated. In the
darkly hilarious finale, the Narrator tells Marla:
"You met me at a very strange time in my life."
Buildings explode around them as
The Pixies' "Where Is My Mind"
leads into the credits. This ending
was actually censored in China,
although, ironically, the censored
version is closer to Palahniuk's novel.
In many ways, Doctor Strange is one of
the more formulaic Marvel origin stories,
with Stephen Strange's character arc having a lot
in common with that of Tony Stark's in the first
Iron Man movie. What a relief it is,
then, when the climax of the movie
breaks significantly from the standard MCU
formula. Whereas most Marvel movies build
up to giant fight scenes between the heroes and
villains, Scott Derrickson's 2016 film finds a
more clever method for the Sorcerer Supreme to
save Earth from the cosmic terror of Dormammu.
Strange's strategy initially appears to be
an attempt at diplomacy — he announces his
intention to "bargain" with Dormammu, at which
point the Dark Dimension ruler promptly kills him.
It soon becomes clear, however, that Strange's
true plan is to annoy Dormammu into submission,
as he has trapped both himself
and Dormammu in a time loop in
which Strange keeps coming back to
be killed again and again and again.
"Dormammu, I've come to bargain."
Eventually, Dormammu gets so sick
of the loop that he agrees to Strange's terms
to leave Earth alone. No doubt, more superhero
movies could benefit from the inventive use of
superpowers displayed in this unique showdown.
Director Adam McKay's Don't Look Up was
one of the most divisive films of 2021.
It was one of Netflix's most watched movies
ever and accrued many award nominations,
including one for Best Picture at
the Oscars, but reviews were mixed.
Even those who generally disliked the apocalyptic
satire, however, have acknowledged that the film
is at its best when it finds genuine pathos
in the characters' final night on Earth.
With the ultra-rich escaping to outer space and
the comet about to deliver the extinction of
mankind, Dr. Randall Mindy decides to spend one
last dinner together with friends and family.
Yule, the Christian anarchist
skater played by Timothée Chalamet,
leads the group in prayer before dinner, and
everyone expresses the things they're grateful for
even as the world is literally ending
around them. Critics may have disagreed
about the movie as a whole, but there's
no denying the power of its final moments.
Many of Pixar's movies save their
most emotional moments for the end.
The ending of Monsters University,
the 2013 prequel to Monsters Inc.,
stands out by elevating what is otherwise
a cute but unexceptional parody of college
movies into something that genuinely lives
up to Pixar's high standard of quality.
There are many family movies
about following your dreams,
but Monsters University is one of the few to
acknowledge that dreams can fail and change. No
matter how hard he tries, Mike Wazowski realizes
he's never going to be scary. That's okay, though,
because he finds there are other things he's
good at — such as working as a scare assistant.
"Mike, you're not scary. Not even
a little. But you are fearless."
Both Mike and Sully end up expelled for all
the trouble they cause, but they find they
don't need to follow the set path of academia
to succeed. Instead, they apply for jobs in the
mailroom at Monsters Inc., and the credits
sequence shows them gradually working their
way up the corporate ladder. It's an unusual but
positive message of flexibility and compromise.
Writer-director Céline Sciamma is talented at many
things, but her greatest talent might be found in
the endings to her movies. Portrait of a Lady on
Fire, her 2019 historical lesbian romance, is a
slow burn with a powerful conclusion. Romantic
tensions gradually build up between the painter
Marianne and her aristocratic subject Héloïse,
but their affair is brief, and Marianne only sees
Héloïse twice after it's over. The first time
is at an art exhibit; the second time is at the
orchestra, and it's this ending which turns the
film into one of the all-time great tearjerkers.
Portrait of a Lady on Fire uses music extremely
sparingly — only in scenes where the characters
are actually performing or singing. As a result,
when music is heard in the film, its effect is
extremely powerful. The orchestra in the final
scene is playing the Presto from "Summer" in
Vivaldi's [vih-VAHL-dee] Four Seasons, the same
piece of music Marianne once played for Héloïse.
Héloïse doesn't know Marianne is observing her
in the audience for this concert, but when she
hears this music, she appears overwhelmed
with the memories of their love. It's an
incredible piece of filmmaking on Sciamma's part,
supported by a superb performance by Adèle Haenel.
At the start of 1973's F for Fake,
filmmaker Orson Welles assures the audience:
"During the next hour, everything you hear from
us is really true, and based on solid fact."
He spends the next hour talking about various
real life hoaxes, from art forgeries to the
fictional news broadcasts in his own
1938 War of the Worlds radio drama.
But F for Fake runs longer than an
hour, and in its final 28 minutes,
it becomes one of the very "fakes"
the first hour was documenting.
Welles is honest about his fakery, of
course. All his assurances of truth at
the beginning were clearly stated to last
just one hour, and at the end of the film,
he openly admits to "lying [his] head
off" during the 17-minute story about
his partner and co-writer Oja Kodar modeling
for and swindling Picasso. In an era of "fake
news," Welles' trolling deconstruction of the
documentary format is more relevant than ever.
Christopher Nolan's 2006 film The
Prestige concludes with several
mind-blowing twists. Each of the magicians is
hiding secrets: For Hugh Jackman's Robert Angier,
the secret is that he's able to pull off
the "Transported Man" magic trick through
actual magic of sorts, cloning himself
with a machine built by Nikola Tesla.
Christian Bale's Alfred Borden performs
the trick using a very different secret:
He's not actually one person, but twin
brothers sharing a single identity.
One Borden is hanged after
being framed for killing Angier,
who's secretly still alive under the identity of
Lord Caldlow. The other Borden gets his revenge
and kills the last remaining Angier, whose theater
burns down with all his dead clones inside.
Great twist endings are hard to pull off,
but The Prestige is a movie designed around
its many revelations, meticulously following
the steps that make a great magic trick work.
Set in a motel outside of Disney World,
The Florida Project centers around Moonee,
a six-year-old girl having fun with her friends
while her loving but neglectful single mother,
Halley, struggles to make ends meet.
It's a movie that's repetitive by design
to best get across the reality of life in poverty,
but the ending shakes up this repetition in a
manner both heartbreaking and absolutely stunning.
Eventually, things get bad enough that child
services come to take Moonee away from Halley.
In this moment of deep pain, Moonee
and her friend Jancey escape and run
away to the Magic Kingdom. People have
debated whether the Disney World scene
is meant to be real or the children's
fantasy — but however you interpret it,
the conclusion makes the film as a
whole even more memorable and affecting.
Fans might argue over which Monty Python movie
is the funniest, but Monty Python's Life of Brian
is definitely the one with the strongest story —
one which leads to the strongest ending by far.
This irreverent, often-censored 1979 comedy
follows Brian, a "very naughty boy" living
in proximity to Jesus who is accidentally
mistaken for the Messiah. At the end of the film,
Brian has been sentenced to death by crucifixion,
and all attempts to save him go horribly awry.
"Rej, what are you going to—"
"Goodbye, Brian. And thanks."
Unable to do anything to escape his slow and
painful death, the other crucified men cheer
Brian up by singing "Always Look on the Bright
Side of Life." Optimistic, nihilistic, absurdist,
extremely British — there are lots of ways you can
describe the comedic juxtaposition of Eric Idle's
silly, upbeat song with the direness of
its context. Whatever you want to call it,
though, it clearly struck a chord. In 2014,
"Always Look on the Bright Side of Life"
was revealed to have been the most frequently
requested funeral song in the United Kingdom.
Neil LaBute's 2006 remake of The Wicker Man is not
considered a good horror movie by most people's
standards. In the final moments of its unrated
cut, however, it certainly becomes memorable.
Though there are several amusing displays of
overacting from Nicolas Cage throughout the film,
none compare to the scene where the
villagers torture him with bees,
resulting in the now-legendary line:
"Not the bees! Oh, they're in my eyes, my eyes!"
In a 2022 interview with IndieWire, Cage claimed
the comedy of this scene was intentional,
and that he and LaBute actually wanted the film
to go further with the ridiculousness. He said:
"It probably would've been more clear how funny
it was if [producer] Avi Lerner let me have the
handlebar mustache that I wanted to wear and be
burned in the bear suit. That would've been so
horrifying, but they didn't go for that because
all the comedy would've emerged from this horror."
He pointed to the horrifying yet also
darkly comedic conclusion of Midsommar
as a more successful example of what
The Wicker Man remake was aiming for.
Michael Curtiz's 1942 drama Casablanca is a
movie so beloved as a classic that basically
every line has become a cliché — and yet
it's still a delight to watch 80 years later.
From beginning to end, Casablanca
is a brilliantly entertaining movie,
with clever writing and captivating romantic
chemistry between Humphrey Bogart's Rick Blane
and Ingrid Bergman's Ilsa Lund.
It's the story's conclusion,
however, that truly seals this as one of
the greatest American films ever made.
Rick, a character who was once a celebrated
freedom fighter but has since become cynical
and disillusioned, regains his heroism at a time
when the world truly needs it. He sacrifices his
change to stay with Ilsa in order to help
her and her husband escape from the Nazis.
"Here's looking at you, kid."
Indeed, Casablanca is a work of wartime
propaganda made with such moral heft
and great storytelling that it elevates
itself to become a powerful work of art.
George Romero's Night of the Living Dead shocked
moviegoers in 1968 with its groundbreaking gore
and fresh take on the zombie mythos. For all
the terror of its flesh-eating undead, though,
the ending of the film shows how ordinary
humans can be the scariest monsters of all. Ben,
the movie's Black hero, has done his best to
survive throughout the film, but in the end,
he's killed by some white men with guns
who seemingly mistake him for a zombie.
Romero didn't intentionally write Night of the
Living Dead with race in mind, but regardless of
what the filmmaker initially intended, the ending
has widely been viewed as a subversive commentary
on racism. Its implications are, unfortunately, no
less scary today than they were when the movie was
first released. You can credit Night of the Living
Dead, and particularly its ending, for helping
lead the way for such racially-conscious
horror films as Candyman and Get Out.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.